we welcome back reports of anti-Semitism
Assa in both the UK and the US and
indeed around the world since the Israel
Hamas War Began many pro Palestine
supporters however believe the criticism
of Israel is being censored by the
claims of hate speech last night Israeli
president Isaac hog told me that a pro
Palestine March planned on the UK's
Armistice Day should be banned so our
claims of anti-Semitism and islamophobia
being used to stifle legitimate
criticism and indeed Free Speech or
rather tensions on our streets in real
Danger of boiling over well here to
debate all this is the founder of the
end Jew hatred movement Brooke Goldstein
the host of system update Glenn greenal
and the author of go back to where you
come from commentator wajahat wajahat
Ali welcome to all of you and let me
start with you Brooke I want to read you
what you tweeted me recently because I
think this will set the tone for this
debate you said peers I've been on the
show I know you to be a fair journalist
but I don't understand why you're giving
these Islam Nazis such a large platform
over and over again to spread their
venom there comes a point when you have
heard their message and you've done your
duty would you likewise host every
single member of the SS in Nazi Germany
for the sake of debunking I hate to say
you're not doing a good job at it
they're lies of propaganda are so
carefully crafted that the more you put
Hass apologies on the more effective
they become asking people to debate them
to debate how many babies were killed
whether it's by beheading or by stabbing
or by burning babies alive is tasteless
and rces the memory of the innocent
Jewish people who've been killed at what
point does your journalism become a
propaganda tool for terrorism they send
their best and brightest to you to
engage in mental masturbation acrobatics
and they're running circles around you
with all due respect enough in the
battle between good and evil there is no
journalistic obligation to continue to
put evil on a platform to be debated so
I mean that seems to me a pretty strong
way to start this debate because what
you seem to be saying is that so long as
I have pro-israeli voices that's fine as
long as I have a lot of people like you
who just have one view of this then I'm
a fair journalist but the moment I Stray
into people who are pro
Palestinian in a very passionate manner
then somehow I'm uh failing in my
journalistic duty and I would say that
that right there is part of the problem
Brook because I have tried to turn this
show into a genuinely Fair platform for
all sides all arguments all all voices
and I think we've been getting the
audiences that that reflects which is
people like it they like to hear both
sides why don't
you so Pierce thank you for bringing up
that tweet um first I want to say that's
not what I'm saying at all there's Pro
Palestinian there's pro-israel but
you've been having Pro Hamas people on
your platform and you're giving them an
opportunity to spew their virent
anti-Semitism and their propaganda that
justifies Hamas terrorism it's one thing
to issues of geopolitics and Nation bro
can you name one right right in front of
me I can't I was replying to something
that uh you had someone on that I was
name one guest I've had in a month you
know I don't have name right now but I
can name someone right now with all with
all respect you tweeted this lengthy
attack on me and my journalistic rer I'm
simply asking
you the people you have on right now
hang on Brooke hang on if you're going
to do that I don't think it's
unreasonable to say who which of my Pro
Palestinian guests expressed support for
Hamas because I must have missed that
was jahat Ali who is on the show right
now with us for example has deep
connections to the Muslim Brotherhood
the Muslim Brotherhood is the mother of
all terrorist organizations it spawned
Hamas a designated terrorist group which
is currently killing both gazan and
Israeli civilians was shahat Ali who is
on the platform with me right now and
your audience needs to know this sat on
the board of the Muslim Student
Association which is widely known to be
a Muslim Brotherhood entity he also has
writings that are crossposted on the
English language website of the Muslim
Brotherhood he has crossposted authors
who call for the eradication of the
Jewish State he's a leading writer at
cap the center for American progress
which also has ties to the Muslim
Brotherhood he has criticized cracking
down on the Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt
and of course he just published an
article saying that he's against Hamas
because it's politically him he is
connected to
the that's who you have on your show
before before I go to him you've just
said he just he' just written a piece
condemning Hamad so you kind of kill
your own argument let me go uh to J well
he's sucking and blowing at the same
time let me go to the man is the prop
that they are using right now let me go
to the man you've been accusing what do
you say to
that well first of all excellent
pronunciation of my name Brooke thank
you also it's pretty amazing that for a
human rights lawyer you really don't
seem to care much about human beings who
happen to be Palestinians or Muslim or
Arab it's like a fireman who's actually
an arsonist but thank you I risk my life
to make a movie about Arab children I
risked my life to make a movie about
Arab children was given an award by the
United Nations for my advocacy work for
Palestinian children good job on doing
your research let him answer you
please you are the hero and you are the
victim but let me say the following uh
let me say that well the person who
accused me of being the Muslim
Brotherhood and the person who's accused
us anyone who's Pro Palestinian of being
a Nazi which is by the way what Brian
Mass said Republican he said there's no
such thing as Palestinian civilians
because they're just like Nazis right
but anyway let me say this cuz PE I've
seen your show I appr can you let speak
you condemn the Muslim Brotherhood let
me say this I'm going to go a step
forward look at this this is what I'm
going to do because I've seen people
with my melanin on pier show I've
proactively been asked to condemn Hamas
I condemn Hamas I condemn Hezbollah I
condemn Islamic Jihad I condemn Muslim
Brotherhood I condemn chocolate hummus I
condemn uh I condemn anti-Semitism I
condemn islamophobia I condemn white
supremacy I also condemn Israel's
occupation I condemn settler violence
against Palestinians that have killed
over 100 people in the West Bank I
condemn Netanyahu using dehumanizing
language that you use such as calling
every Palestinian amalik I condemn the
Heritage Minister saying that he wants
to drop a nuke a nuke on Gaza I have
condemned all of that do you Brooke join
me in condemning everything that I have
condemned because I think as a human
rights lawyer anyone who cares about
Humanity they should condemn everything
that I have condemned Brooke 100% why if
you condemn the Muslim Brotherhood are
you publishing with the center for
American progress which is strong ties
to the Muslim Brotherhood and why do
allow your papers to be crossposted on
Muslim Brotherhood websites why have you
denied Jewish IND genuity to Jud you
know what I'm going to get I'm going to
jump States for I'm going to jump in
come and you say these things on
television but you write the exact
opposite writing I'm going to jump in
and come to Glenn he's been waiting very
patiently as as you guys have been going
at it Glen in a way this kind of is
reflective of of the debate I I thought
we should be having because it seems to
me that uh a lot of people are simply
not prepared to tolerate other views
generally in society we've got to a
place where people get cancelled if they
don't toe align don't have the opinion
that a certain group of people have
decided is the only opinion that's
allowed how have we got there how has it
been through this war I mean to me
watching Twitter X as it now is in this
war is like this terrible assault on the
brain um it's it's just people screaming
in a self-righteous often fake news
oriented way uh trying to scream their
opponents into submission where has
honest democratic debate gone what do we
do about
this yeah I think you're right that uh
Brooke your first guest is a perfect
reflection of what has gone so wrong
with this discourse ever since October
7th she did two things that has been
really pathological in terms of how
we're trying to conduct discourse about
a very serious issue number one she
equates every person who criticizes
Israel or who defends the Palestinian
cause of being an Islam and Nazi or
somehow being associated with terrorists
as she did with wajahat with who might
have a lot of differences but he has
never done anything like that the idea
that the center for American progress
can I you are doing exactly you must
let you had a speak I want to hear from
Glenn the idea that the center for
American progress is some sort of crypto
terrorist group but in fact it is the
most mainstream Democratic party
platform that hosted Benjamin yet nahu
that completely supports Israel just
like the Democratic party does is
derangement and this attempt to accuse
everyone of being a bigot or an
anti-semite the minute they express any
criticism of Israel I think is very
toxic but the worst thing here is that
ever since a month ago when this started
we have had a Spate of censorship
throughout the West aimed only at one
side which is the pro Palestinian side
France banned All Pro Palestinian
protests you can have pro-israel
protests you can go and say you think
Gaza should be flattened that all gazin
should be eradicated like many people
say what you can't do though is March in
opposition to the French policy the
British Home Secretary said waving a
Palestinian flag may be a crime in the
US they're banning Pro Palestinian
groups so we could have our differences
obviously this is a very inflammatory
issue but what we should not do is try
and suppress healthy debate through
State censorship through Banning one
side from expressing themselves or
accusing everybody of being a terrorist
and a Nazi because they express
criticism for the Israeli government
something which many Jews like myself
and many Israelis do as well okay let me
go to Brooke I want to ask Brook I want
to ask you a question I'm actually is
this Pro Palestinian okay Mur and
bludgeoning of a Jewish man at a pro-
Hamas rally these are not pro
Palestinian rallies what is banned is
pro- Hamas in Europe Hamas is a
designated terrorist group and you
should understand the difference between
that when you lock students in a library
at Cooper's Union and bang on the door
and threaten them with violence that is
not free speech when you beat up Jews
because you are projecting your hatred
of a foreign government on somebody
because of what they look like or what
their religion is that is bigotry that
is not free speech and your other
two speak at BR I want bring please to
respond to that Brook you can't just
keep talking you made you've made a
powerful Point let me go to a jar hat
for
respon this is the big difference
between you and me Brooke and there are
many differences that I have the
capacity to empathize with the suffering
of the Jewish people and with
Palestinians that when I see
anti-Semitism when I see Jews were
afraid in Europe and in America I
condemn it when I see Muslims afraid of
islamophobia I condemn it when I see
wadia who was a six-year-old boy
murdered murdered simply because he was
Palestinian American I condemn it when I
see this man this 69y old man and
they're they're researching it right now
to see whether or not it was a hate
crime I will condemn it the difference
between me and you is that when I see
dead children when I see 4,000
Palestinian kids who are killed it horri
me as a human rights lawyer I amazed why
this does not horrify you when you see
4,000 kids killed this does not Shock
you for you it's collateral
damage now the IDF yesterday said can I
finish can I the ID yesterday said and
un the IDF yesterday said stop
interrupting me please IDF yesterday
said that of the 10,000 people killed
only 60 were haras operatives so that
means that means that 10,000 people were
killed by Israel in the past month 4,000
children more kids killed in the past
month than in the past 3 years of all
war zones uh the conflict zones combined
I say it's inhumane and indecent do you
condemn the 4,000 kids that have been
killed and as of yesterday the ID said
only 60 people were H operatives human
rights law the pro Israel the pro
so-called Hamas Palestinian movement is
that we mourn the death of all civilian
Ians where the pro Palestinian Hamas
protest after October the 7th were out
on the street celebrating the death of
dead Jewish civilians that is the
difference and the other difference
between you you fail
to to bring cuse and effect you fail to
understand the concept of cause remains
my show at the moment inter let that's
enough for now I want bring law is very
clear you had a chance to respond
international law is very you had a
chance to
respond other panelist Glenn I want to
bring Glenn I'm sorry Glenn so I just
let me let me ask Glen Glenn you're
you're a yeah you're a Jewish man uh
when you look at what is going on here I
I will be completely candid I said this
to other guests in the last uh couple of
weeks I found what happened October the
7th to be a un an unbelievable scale of
barbaric terrorism Beyond thing I've
seen in my lifetime to be honest with
you the way it was done and I completely
understand Israel's not only right but
duty to defend itself but is there a
line here that Israel shouldn't cross in
its attempt to eradicate Hamas when you
see
10,000 Palestinians killed within the
space of four weeks and we know it's
going to get much much higher and so
many are children is there a moral line
that Israel shouldn't Cross or is their
argument that they've got to get rid of
herass and in war you have collateral
damage and in this case it's the
civilians who are living around herass
and it's awful but that's what has to
happen every decent person found the
Hamas Massacre on October 7th
reprehensible and morally unjustifiable
the question though is what does that
mean that everything that Israel does in
response becomes justifiable and the
answer is clearly not just like
everything the United States did in
response to 911 which was also morally
horrific and unjustifiable killed 3,000
Americans everything that the United
States did in response wasn't morally
justifiable simply by virtue of the fact
that they claimed to be doing it in the
name of avenging 911 they tortured
people there were secret camps in
Guantanamo they invaded and destroyed
Iraq a country of 26 million people
giving rise to Isis the laws of war were
created after World War II ironically
when the world looked at what happened
in World War II the atrocities there and
said we know there are going to be Wars
but there have to be limits you cannot
collectively punish a population that is
a war crime because certain people in
that country have done bad things you
cannot just bomb people indiscriminately
without regard to civilian life and how
many tens of thousands or even a hundred
thousand Palestinians does Israel have
the right to kill in the name of trying
to destroy Hamas of course there are
humanitarian limits and laws of war that
were created after World War II that the
nerenberg tribunal said apply to every
country in the Future No Matter How just
your cause and I thought that was the
lesson of 911 that just because a
country is enraged and acting with a
quest for violence doesn't mean that
everything they do in the name of
avenging that terrorist attack becomes
justifiable or morally defensible much
of what the United States did wasn't and
much of what Israel is doing isn't
either okay Glen powerful words I thank
you for joining unforunately we we run
out of time but I will I will get you
back on the program because you've been
a terrific guest tonight uh I've enjoyed
that debate want to say is that Jews
have led the protest Jews have actually
led the protest Jews calling
for them to okay I've got to leave it
there I'm sorry P thank you very much
indeed to my panel I appreciate you all
joining me Glenn Brooke with hat thank
you very much
indeed